du hast dich ja schick gemacht
sehr schön wie meinst du das guten
termine gibt es noch keine
zumindest keine zu denen ich dich
mitnehmen kann na gut
egal also hier sitzt die
geschäftsführung also ich wir sind
bestens ausgestattet und hammer aussicht
oder mir prima und hier sitze ich du
sitzt
und wo ist mein rechner genaueste
erstmal nicht kommt vielleicht nächste
woche du bist dahin könntest du das hier
kopieren und in dem auf und ab hüpfen
die deponierung funktioniert was wir
sicher oder ach ja ich könnte jetzt
wirklich guten kaffee gebrochen ist
alexander kunz standard wie kann ich
ihnen helfen
für wen ist das denn für dich eine
kleine entschädigung für die schlechte
laune von wins sind schließlich habe ich
dir das alles angeboten
es gibt geschenke
philipp aber das ist auch nicht nötig
doch doch ist das ich wow du hast es
momentan so schwer und ich würde gerne
wieder ein schönes lächeln sehen toll
wenn ich hier nach noch helfen kann dann
sag bescheid arbeiten mag absagen es ist
schon halb acht
vielleicht kann ich dir helfen wird 4
wenn du möchtest dass ihre kleider
aussehen wie wolkenkratzer und schiefer
kann ich ein glas wasser angeblich
übernehmen das von giotto philipp dazu
ich kann das nicht annehmen
wirklich nicht aber warum denn nicht
ist doch viel zu teuer und auch wegen
mag ich glaube nicht dass er das toll
findet